because you've thought
quite a bit about dark matter as well is
do you have any kind of hypothesis
interesting hypothesis we already
mentioned
a few about what is dark matter and what
are the
uh possible paths that we could take to
unlock the mystery of dark what is dark
matter yeah so what we need is some
anomalies
that would hint what the nature of the
dark matter is
or to detect it in the laboratory there
are lots of laboratory experiments
searching but it's like searching for a
needle in a haystack because there are
so many possibilities for the
type of particle that it may be
but maybe at some point you know we'll
find either a particle or black hole
says dark matter or something else
but you also may be sorry to interrupt
to comment about what is dark matter
like what it's just a name we're
assigned to what
so most of the community believes that
it's a particle
that we haven't yet detected it doesn't
interact with light so
it's dark but the question is what does
it interact with
and how can we find it and the for many
years
uh physicists were guided by the idea
that it's some extension of the
standard model of particle physics but
then they said
oh we will find some clues from the
large hadron collider
about its nature or maybe it's related
to supersymmetry which is a new symmetry
that we haven't found any evidence for
in both cases the large hadron collider
did not give us any clues
and other people searched for specific
types of particles in the laboratory and
didn't find any
a couple of years ago actually around
the time that i worked on umuamua
i also worked on the possibility that
the dark matter particles may have a
small electric charge
which is a speculation but nobody
complained about it
and you know it was published and i
regard it more as
of a speculation than the artificial
origin of umumua
and to me i apply you know as far as i'm
concerned i apply the same scientific
tools in both cases there is an anomaly
that
led me to that discussion which has to
do with the
hydrogen being called in the early
universe more than we expected so we
suggested
maybe the dark matter particles have
some small charge
but you deal with anomalies by exploring
possibilities that's the only way to do
it and then
collecting more data to check those and
searching for technological
signatures is the same as any other part
of
our scientific endeavor we make
hypotheses
and we collect data and i don't see any
reason for having a taboo
on this subject
you